voilà une petite beauté nous sommes avec
chris marquez avant de retrouver camille
combal et le qu'est ce qu'on pense mon
frère et puis il aurait une grosse
révélation à nous faire un camille
combal crise oui les vous affrontez
temps de la danse
je suis inquiet dans la danse mot crise
est très simple il y a le marathon de la
danse est très simple on va démarrer par
un boys band c'est vous qui allez
démarrer ensuite il y aura de la danse
hip hop
ensuite il y aura de la danse russe
ensuite il y aura la danse country et
ensuite il y aura une fan de danse de
l'épaule arrivé en plateau comme ceux ci
et c'est vous qui allez voter sur
docteur et son boubou pour nous dire qui
a fait la meilleure danse vous allez
démarrer la crise vous y allez vous
enchaînez des danses 15 secondes par
danse s'est tout de suite c'est le
marathonman hausse
attention crise trois deux un top ses
parents mais moi
juppé
nazim gillani crise
ok
moins de chance que ça
chances que ça
oui
brava trice pour la ratonnade ans bruce
katz et chris marquez moi j'ai besoin
j'aime bien nous mettre dans la peau
d'un danseur c'est parti oliva vous me
donner le top quand vous voulez on est
deux mois
deux filles
à
la nation et
et
je lacombe et j'ai fini g.lacombe et la
faune dans le rôle le garder il se prend
vraiment pour un danseur de coudrie je
suis arrivé j'ai fait du sud à couper un
peu d'espoir pour cela eric à penser
tous marqué ce qu'a gagné merci légal
c'est toi c'est pour un univers si jouer
à fond dans l'eau l'eau
j'ai eu un pépin
vraiment je dansais avec le gage fait
mais si julien courbet mais le gars mais
à fond dans ce monde quoi je n'ai jamais
voté en fait j'ai fait la connerie j'ai
pas fait couler non mais ça s'est vu
vous étiez magnifique bouge mais j'ai
bien tellement heureux parce que j'ai
d'avoir des nouvelles du faucon vient
d'arriver à rotterdam
oh